okay it is time for one of the most
popular segments that we do with a very
small section of the audience a lot of
people do not care about the segment but
the people that like it really liked it
and we're furious when it went away so
we've brought it back every three or
four weeks I will recommend some books
to you that I've read some will be
fiction some will be nonfiction all of
my recommendations from this week and
previous weeks are at david pakman.com
slash recommendations if you use the
links on that page to buy any of these
books we get a little slice
to quote andrew yang of your amazon
transaction so please do that check it
out I've got a whole bunch of great
stuff recommended david pakman.com slash
recommendations today it is a big week
for recommendations I will have two
non-fiction books to begin with and then
to fiction books first non-fiction book
billion dollar whale by Tom Wright and
Bradley hope this is a fascinating caper
I've got my Harvard co-op bookstore
bookmark in they're still very Boston
centric extraordinary this is a really
great caper about a Malaysian guy named
Joe Lowe who did a combination of some
really bad things and some really
entrepreneurial things which is often
the case in in many other circumstances
as well and this is the story of how he
built relationships how he got into the
business world and ultimately how he
took advantage of a lot of different
people I don't want to say too much
because really if you don't know the
story it is interesting to learn about
it as you read the book could not
recommend this more highly it is
certainly a page-turner it's not short
it's 400 pages but I found that it
really went by quickly because you it
just sucks you in and you want to read
it if you like books such as wrote the
Jonestown about Jim Jones or the book
about that I recommend that a few weeks
ago about how they found Ross Ulbricht
the creator of the dark web the Silk
Road rather
if you like books like blow about drug
dealer drug trafficker really George
Jung if that genre is interesting to you
then you will really like this book okay
billion dollar whale Tom right and
Bradley hope highly recommended okay I
think I might have mentioned this book
in passing before I don't remember how I
came across this it's called consider
the fork a history of how we cook and
eat by B Wilson now you might think who
cares how they first made the first
tablespoon that is not what this book is
about this book it's a lot of Sociology
about the ways in which having
containers for food like having a bowl
what would nutrition and cuisine be like
if we didn't even have bowls or utensils
what changed when fire was first used to
cook food and what was the effect on
people's bodies and people's teeth
really interesting stuff about how
people's teeth changed once we no longer
ate food by sort of taking a hunk of
something biting down and using a knife
to cut a piece off that significantly
changed people's teeth it's a very very
interesting book I guess I'd call it a
combination sort of like science
sociology history and I guess it's sort
of as a cooking book as well and in some
strict sense the book is considered the
fork a history of how we cook and eat by
B Wilson don't miss this one and now to
fiction recommendations I actually read
this book in English although because
that's just what someone handed to me
although I'm told that in Spanish it is
it is delightful this is the club Dumas
by Arturo Pettis Rivera who is a Spanish
author this is a sort of caper that
pulls in real historical stuff about the
author of The Count of Monte Cristo
Alexandre Dumas combined with a caper
about a book dealer and antique book
trader investigator type of guy and it
weaves a very
compelling narrative and I think it is
so the cover says that it's a cross
between echo and Anne Rice I've never
read Anne Rice I have read Umberto Eco
and there are definitely there's a feel
that is similar to elements of Umberto
Eco in this so check that out
the club Dumas are two de Paris Roberta
is the author and lastly this is someone
we've interviewed on the program
Blake crouches book dark matter I've
read a bunch of stuff by Blake Crouch I
think there's a TV series written by him
or based on his writing called good
behavior or bad behavior I don't
remember exactly I've read the book but
this is one of his newer books not his
newest it is dark in a lot of ways it
just so happens the name of the book is
dark matter but it is dark in many ways
I have let a few friends borrow this and
everybody is quite taken with it it is
once again a major major page-turner I
would be shocked if you can put this
book down I know that if you have done
juniors new book then you might be
focusing on that instead of other things
but I recommend this instead dark matter
by Blake Crouch all of these
recommendations available for free the
recommendations you might have to buy
the books at david pakman.com slash
recommendations and remember if you use
any of the links on that page to buy
these books we get a little bit of a cut
off of the cost of the books